ein großer Auto zu belieferer mehr als
1.000 Mitarbeiter und Olaf Scholz
erzählt lachend über einen Bürger der
sie einen Gasofen angeschafft hat viel
zu besprechen bei 8:15 Uhr heute Abend
mit diesen Gästen Automarkt Friedrich
der sich schwer um die deutsche
Industrie sorgt um mit seinen Büchern
regelmäßig die bestsellisten stimmt ich
bin gespannt
bildpolitikredakteur Sebastian Geißler
er sorgt sich um die Bodenhaftung
unserer Politiker und sagt Kanzler
Scholz unsere Existenzen sind kein Witz
Politikwissenschaftler Werner Patzelt
empfindet die Lage auch nicht als Scherz
sondern waren vor einem wutwinter last
but not least datenexpertin Katharina
Schiller sie sagt die Regierung hat mit
corona-daten gespielt und getäuscht auf
das Thema bin ich ganz gespannt sie
merken schon wir haben 14 Stoff heute
Abend viel gestritten wird gerade auch
über das Bürgergeld und das ist mein
Thema heute Abend in ab dem ersten
Januar möchte die Ampelkoalition die
noch aus der Agenda 2010 stammende
Grundsicherung Hartz IV ersetzen doch es
gibt viele Kritik die Union kritisiert
beispielsweise die geplante zweijährige
Karenzzeit für die Prüfung von Wohnen
und Vermögen in dieser Zeit würde nach
den Plänen der Ampel der Staat heiz- und
etwaige Mietkosten ohne zu prüfen ob der
leistungsbezirk eine angemessene Wohnung
lebt übernehmen auch spielt die Höhe
eines möglicherweise vorhandenen
Vermögens keine Rolle
mich da schon ob das die richtigen
Signale sind denn während sich laut
einem heutigen weltbericht für die
Mittelschicht Mehrarbeit kaum noch lohnt
könnte das ein falsches Signal sein der
Grund warum es sich nicht lohnt die
steuerbelastungs laut dem Ifo-Institut
für viele Einkommensgruppen ohne
Leistungsanreize ich sehe persönlich
nicht erst seit der corona-pandemie ein
beunruhigendes Bedürfnis der
Bundesregierung Menschen zu finanzieren
anstelle von der Abhängigkeit des
Staates benötigen wir Motivation zur
Mehrarbeit die sich finanziell auch
lohnt aber hier würde ich die Frage die
Runde Stellen Herr Friedrich macht ist
der Staat Arbeitslosen zu leicht absolut
und vor allem bringt immer mehr Menschen
in die Abhängigkeit vom Staat natürlich
Menschen die abhängig sind die gehen
nicht auf die Straße die gehen nicht
protestieren die werden nicht
unzufrieden aber beißt nie in die Hand
die einen selber füttert und natürlich
ist es wenig Anreiz noch was zu
verdienen immer mehr Mittelständler
sagen mehr warum sie überhaupt noch
arbeiten gehen ich habe rekordabgaben
und es sind 200 Euro mehr die ich
lediglich habe dann bleibe ich doch
lieber zu Hause liegt die Füße auf den
Tischen schauen bisschen Bild TV
immer eine ganz tolle Idee sie würden
also Finanzminister Christian Lindner
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck und
Kanzler Olaf Scholz unterstellen dass
sie Menschen abhängig machen wollen um
sie Gefüge zu machen Sozialismus ist ja
wieder die Lösung bei allem wir sind
noch immer mehr Umverteilung was die
meisten Deutschen nicht wissen linke
Tasche ist rechte Tasche das heißt wenn
der Staat Geld verschenkt muss ja sehr
irgendwo anders herbekommen und wir sind
der Staat das heißt entweder über
Steuererhöhungen oder über neue Schulden
für die wir jeweils haften oder halt
zahlen und es begreifen die meisten
nicht und aus diesem Grund ist es
natürlich eine Art abhängigmachung der
Menschen von der Politik damit die nicht
unzufrieden sind dass die Politik sich
aufspielen kann und sagen kann wir haben
die Krise gelöst wir geben euch doch ein
bisschen was an Geld ein kleines
zögerchen damit ihr Ruhe gibt Brot und
Spiele all over again Herr patell würden
sie damit gehen ist der Staat doch kein
Weihnachtsmann mit Rauschebart sondern
eigentlich sind die Geschenke eher süßes
Gift
jene die den Staat leiten nehmen gerne
die Rolle des Weihnachtsmannes an und
hoffen dass dann die kleinen auch
jauchzen vor Freude über die schönen
Geschenke ich glaube weil ich nicht das
so böse Absichten wir wollen die Leute
abhängig machen dahinter stehen es ist
einfach der in Deutschland auf den
Wiederaufbau nach dem 30-jährigen Krieg
Zurückgehen der Glaube dass der Staat
die Verpflichtung hat als wohlmeinender
Vater um die im Grunde ja unmündigen
unselbständigen Bürger sich zu kümmern
das ist der grundreflex und er ist
naturgemäß bei Sozialdemokraten
wesentlich stärker ausgeprägt als bei
Liberalen und da sind sich dann die
großen Parteien von der CDU bis zu den
Grünen und Sozialdemokraten von der
Linken gar nicht lang zu reden einig
dass der Staat ein aktivierender Start
sein muss denn der Bürger ohne dass der
Staat in fördert fordert oder belohnt
würde ja gar nicht aktiv und diese
grundlegende aktive Stadt gegen das
Bürgergeld also CDU kämpft gerade sehr
stark da ist aufgewacht und begreift
dass es hier ein systematisches Problem
gibt wenn die Abstände zwischen dem was
ich durch Arbeit und dem was ich bekomme
wenn ich mich vom Staat betiteln lasse
zu gering sind dann wird natürlich ein
neues Jobwunder nicht stattfinden können
jetzt schon sind bei vielen Leuten die
reden zu hören ich will eine
Work-Life-Balance ich will ja gar nicht
voll arbeiten mir lang dein halber Job
ich brauche ja auch meine Zeit um mich
zu erholen an dieser Stelle braucht es
tatsächlich eine Mentalitätswandel und
den wird wahrscheinlich nur eine sich
verschärfende
not die dann auch den einzelnen so weit
betrifft dass der Staat ihn nicht mehr
vor den fairnissen des Lebens bewahren
kann trifft zu diesem Mentalität ist
nicht die richtige Motivation um das
einmal zusammenzubringen
Motivation sagen viele manch andere
sagen nein es sei ganz im Gegenteil ein
Bürger der nicht arbeiten muss der
stellt eben deswegen seine Arbeitskraft
der Gesellschaft zur Verfügung der
Gesellschaft ging es viel besser müssen
die Leute nicht zu früh aufstehen und
kämen dann ausgepowert nach Hause und
das ist dann eben sozusagen der
Unterschied beraten auf die man sich
bezieht und es ist der Unterschied in
der ideologischen Grundhaltung glaube
ich sozusagen dass der Mensch edelhil
hilfreich und gut ist oder glaube ich
dass er sich nur dann so richtig
anstrengt wenn es tatsächlich den Zwang
gibt sich anzustängen gehen wir einmal
in die Details des Bürgergeldes rein ich
habe eben schon dieses Sonderform also
Schonvermögen angesprochen das würde
60.000 Euro betragen und Christian
Lindner sagt zum Beispiel man sollte
darüber nicht zu sehr debattieren um
nicht in einen schäbigkeitswettbewerb
hereinzukommen da würde ich gerne
Sebastian Geister aus unserer Politik
Redaktion fragen wie du das siehst was
das schon Vermögen das Sondervermögen
betrifft was die ersten zwei Jahre nicht
angegriffen wird also mir macht das
ehrlicherweise ein bisschen fassungslos
ist genau wie du gesagt hast es sind
60.000 Euro für den ersten
Leistungsbezieher und dann für die
Bedarfsgemeinschaft ist es so da kommen
dann noch ich glaube es sind 30.000 Euro
pro Person dazu
150.000 Euro die vom Staat sozusagen
also die nicht angetastet werden müssen
die ich nicht selbst verbrauchen muss
und der Staat zahlt mir trotzdem schon
Geld
dass er arbeitet werden muss von uns
allen vom Steuerzahler das macht mich
fassungslos wie man überhaupt auf die
Idee kommen kann das ja so viel zu hoch
angesetzt das sollte so nicht sein
hier ist natürlich jetzt die Frage dass
meinte Christel Linda mit diesem
schäbigkeitswettbewerb wenn jemand
Schicksalsschlag hat da reinfällt ob es
nicht fairer wäre dieses schon Vermögen
erstmal zu behalten aber nicht in dieser
Höhe also bin ich 150.000 Euro auf der
hohen Kante habe vielleicht ein Haus
besitze vielleicht mehrere Autos noch
dann finde ich es zumutbar dass das
angetastet wird zumindest das Bar
Vermögen das schon wir sprechen jetzt ja
gar nicht darüber also das jetzt die
Regelsätze angehoben werden wie sehr die
Hartz IV Regelsätze bislang sind wenn da
50 € drauf kommt Inflationsausgleich das
kann man ja machen das ja auch richtig
da geht im übrigen auch die Union mit da
gehen wir wohl auch die FDP mit das kann
man machen aber 150.000 Euro schon
Vermögen das ist unmittelbar glaube ich
auch kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass
das so durchgeht damit der Bundesrat ob
das dann durchgeht wie stehen sie zum
Bürgergeld ich halte es auch für
hochproblematisch genau aus dem Punkt
wir können ja überhaupt nicht berechnen
was da fair wäre sind wir bei dem Punkt
was das zumutbar was es nicht zumutbar
ähnliche Diskussion führen wir jetzt
gerade Richtung bedarfsorientierte
energiepreisbremse wir haben überhaupt
nicht die Daten um zu Mitteln was
ermitteln was soll überhaupt
Kinderbedarf sein macht es ein
Unterschied ob sich jemand darum kümmert
dass ein günstigen Energieversorger hat
und da vielleicht wirklich auch tagelang
wochenlang im Internet sucht und
versucht sich da auch selber auch und
und Energie zu sparen oder sagt man
einfach eine mega der Start wird schon
übernehmen
ich habe eine eine spannende Zahl noch
die hat Jens teutrine von der FDP ganz
stark beworben und zwar die
Hinzuverdienst Regeln für Jugendliche um
mal vielleicht ein positive Fakt beim
Bürgergeld zu finden und zwar bislang
ist es so Hartz IV bestraft aktuell
Jugendliche also sie dürfen von dem 450
Euro Job nur 170 Euro behalten wenn die
Eltern Hartz IV Empfänger sind ist das
für Sie Herr Friedrich der richtige
Schritt in die richtige Richtung dass
die Jugendlichen hinzuverdienen dürfen
egal wie ob die Eltern Hartz 4 haben
oder nicht absolut also generell sollte
Arbeit sich wieder lohnen dass man
einfach Akzept höhere Freibeträge nicht
nur für die Jugendlichen für die Kinder
von Hartz IV Empfängern sind auch für
die Hartz IV Empfänger an sich selbst
dass sie wieder in den Arbeitsprozess in
die Arbeitswelt reinkommen Steuern
zahlen mal nur durch Steuereinnahmen und
solche Sachen wieder leisten aber ich
glaube tatsächlich dass es hier auch um
eine Art wählergeschenk ist dass man
einfach versucht ein Kreuzchen zu
ergattern für die nächste Wahl und
dahingehend sehen wir diese Umverteilung
damit der die breite Masse wohl gesonnen
ist den Parteien geht es dann
verabschieden und deswegen bin ich ganz
stark dagegen ist es der falsche Ansatz
und es wird wahrscheinlich mehr Geld
kosten mehr Probleme eruieren weil wir
brauchen ja eigentlich die arbeitende
Bevölkerung wir haben ein demografisches
Problem wir brauchen nicht weniger
Kräfte wir brauchen Fachkräfte überall
den Menschen die Firmen suchen
händeringend nach Arbeitnehmern und
finden keine und dann erzähl noch so die
Leute zu verleiten zu sagen kommt bleibt
zu Hause es lohnt sich sowieso nicht zu
arbeiten das ist der falsche Ansatz
absolut das ist genau das Problem ich
glaube übrigens auch nicht da bin ich
bei einem Patzelt ich glaube nicht dass
der Mensch zur Arbeit gezwungen werden
muss also aber wenn ich natürlich
rational mache dass man sagt ich bleibe
lieber zu Hause weil ich nämlich als
vierköpfige Familie am Ende dann 3000
noch was Euro im Monat bekomme die Miete
wird ja auch übernommen dann ist es eben
rational eigentlich zu sagen ich gehe
eigentlich zur Arbeit ich kriege ja
sogar mehr Geld wenn ich zu Hause bleibe
das kann der Staat eigentlich nicht
ernsthaft ermöglichen so aber Herr
Patzelt warum fällt es denn im Staat so
schwer dieses fordern und fördern
durchzusetzen also Hartz IV ist ja auch
nicht das richtige System um jetzt
Menschen zu fördern das würde ich jetzt
zum Beispiel nicht sagen das Bürgergeld
scheint jetzt auch wieder seine Tücken
zu haben warum ist es denn so schwierig
vielleicht nicht einfach die Steuerlast
etwas runterzunehmen der Staat ist der
dabei immer größere sogenannte
Sondervermögen aufzulegen also
Verschuldungen auf sich zu nehmen und
wird allmählich an die Grenzen seiner
finanziellen Möglichkeiten getrieben da
liegt es natürlich nahe wie auch jetzt
die Debatte ist dass man eben die
Steuern erhöht und um sozusagen bei
nicht allzu vielen Wählern hier Missmut
zu erzeugen sagten es wäre nur die
besser verdienenden besteuert die aber
ohnehin schon an großen Teil unserer
stand zwei der Steuerzahler also wissen
Sie eigentlich viel zu Weltmeister am
Steuer zahlen ja ohne wollen immer
Weltmeister werden
immer höher und Stärke beim Fußball wäre
es besser wenn man Weltmeister würde
aber auch Polizist wahrscheinlich nicht
in Reichweite ich glaube das wesentliche
Problem ist die Demokratie also
Demokratie ist nichts falsch aber sie
setzt für Politiker folgenden Anreiz
wenn ich in den Wahlkampf gehe was Gott
lob alle vier Jahre der Fall ist wenn
ich den Wahlkampf gehe muss ich den
Leuten klar machen können was ich für
sie getan habe und am klarsten ist so
etwas klar zu machen wenn ich sage du
bist jetzt in der Hinsicht besser
gestellt dort haben wir die Wohltat
verteilt dort haben wir jenes getan wir
haben die Lebensumstände verbessert
ein Politiker der hintritt und sagt wir
müssen jetzt erst einmal die
Staatsausgaben kürzen und du wirst es
auch fühlen denn manche Unterstützung
für dich wird entfallen der wird sich
schwer tun im Wald haben wir es einmal
ganz konkret machen mit welchen drei
Punkten könnte man Hartz IV oder wenn
man es dann das Bürgergeld nennen wollen
würde reformieren ich glaube das ist gar
nicht mehr reformierbar man muss es
entweder in der Klarheit lassen in der
Bundeskanzler Schröder ist eingeführt
hat fordern und fördern so dass es auch
wirklich persönlich ein Unterschied
macht ob ich zur Arbeit gehe oder nicht
oder man löst das ganze auf früher
hatten wir ja den stigmatisierenden
Effekt dass das was später Hartz IV ist
Sozialhilfe ist da wollte ja schon
eigentlich niemand sich hier
stigmatisieren lassen aus der
Sozialhilfe wird jetzt über Hartz IV des
Bürgergeld und am Schluss merkt man der
richtig gute Bürger ist der der mit
Dankbarkeit vom Staat das Geld nimmt und
dann nicht aufmuckt noch einmal ich
glaube nicht dass das sozusagen eine
finstere Absicht dahinter ist aber es
ist natürlich die Freude
ist dazu noch derjenige der das vom
Staat nimmt was im Politiker vorsagen so
musst du denken dass es richtig ich
erkläre es dir denn dass es Wissenschaft
das ist jetzt der allgemeine etwas das
ist etwas führt jetzt zu weit darauf
kommen wir bei euch noch aber noch
einmal ein sehr Friedrich die Frage ob
sie dann drei Punkte haben also ich gebe
schon mal ein ich finde es gut dass zum
Beispiel bei den Jugendlichen die Sätze
erhöht werden also sie auch die
kompletten 450 Euro behalten dürfen und
nicht mehr nur noch 170 Euro haben sie
einen konkreten Punkt mehr als 4 den sie
verändern würden ja ich würde Hartz4
tatsächlich abschaffen ich glaube der
nächste Schritt die nächste Stufe wird
nun ab bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen
sein die dann das Staat verteilen wird
an alle Bedürftigen die wirklich
Bedürftigen Bedürfnisse haben und Geld
brauchen aber man kann Hartz4 nicht mehr
reformieren dass es durch dessen sich
alle Experten einig das Bürgergeld ist
leider eine Verschlimmbesserung wiederum
wird sehr sehr viel Geld kosten
bürokratische Aufwand ohne Ende und auch
im Endeffekt wieder scheitern in wenigen
Jahren werden wir hier sitzen genau
darüber damit er sprechen dass es
ebenfalls geschadet ist genauso wie
Hartz IV das war jetzt wenig Hoffnung
und wir gehen jetzt auch weiter mit
wenig Hoffnungen leider er bekommt zu
ihrer These
Realisierung würde ich sagen
dementsprechend es geht düster weiter es
wird heute aber noch sonniger ja auf
jeden Fall es gibt realistisch weiter
würde ich jetzt mal sagen weil wir sehen
doch dass Deutschland auf dem nieder auf
dem absteigenden Ast ist wir sehen eine
Insolvenzwelle die uns jetzt schon tot
und auch natürlich Idee
Industrialisierung wir sehen Krisen in
unglaublichem Maße wir sehen die
Inflation wir sind die Rezession wir
sehen Energiekrise und jetzt auch noch
Politiker die völlig überfordert sind
und von einer Krise zur nächsten hecheln
und wirklich keine Krise lösen ganz im
Gegenteil teilweise sogar verschlimmern
durch ihre Aktionen und natürlich
belasten uns Bürger die Energie und
Strompreise immens aber natürlich auch
die deutsche Wirtschaft und die deutsche
Wirtschaft ist am klagen und warnt vor
einer Insolvenz weil und waren vor einer
der Industrialisierung wir haben BASF
gesehen die gesagt haben sie werden
nicht mehr in Europa investieren das ist
eine lernsignal weil BASF ist an der
Hauptarbeitgeber in Deutschland extrem
wichtig und wir sehen das immer mehr
Unternehmen überlegen abzuwandeln ihre
Produktion zu verlagern um günstige
Energie zu haben um wirkungssicherheit
zu haben und vor allem eine Planbarkeit
weil die fehlt weil wir haben eine
Politik die jeden Tag eine andere Idee
hat und wir sehen ja dass die Sanktionen
uns massiv Schaden und deswegen
versuchen jetzt die ersten Unternehmen
nach ins Ausland zu gehen bzw ihre
Produktion zu verlagern gehen in
Kurzarbeit und parallel natürlich gibt
es auch viele Unternehmen die jetzt in
die Insolvenz gehen müssen weil sie die
Energie und Strompreise nicht mehr
bezahlen können und jetzt muss die
Politik unbedingt aktiv werden bevor
hier auch unser sozialer Frieden und
nicht unser Wohlstand auf dem Spiel
stehen weil die Menschen werden auf die
Straße gehen darüber nach mit Herrn
patzeltreten aber tatsächlich ist es so
dass es jetzt um die Existenz um die
Zukunft Deutschlands geht und da gibt es
verschiedene Sachen die man jetzt
angehen muss also natürlich muss die
Politik handeln stimme ich Ihnen
vollkommen zu warum wollen Sie jetzt an
die Sanktionen gegen Russland ran das
hatte ich für einen schweren Fehler also
wollen sie jetzt im Ernst sagen jawohl
wir beziehen wieder mehr Gas aus wir
machen trotzdem zwei ist jetzt ja in
Luft gesprengt und so aber
das kann ja nicht das kann ja eigentlich
nicht ernst sein also was soll der
Westen jetzt einfach zuschauen wie
Russland wie Putin in der Ukraine
Zivilisten regelrecht da muss man ja
sagen abschlachtet das kann nicht sein
Wirtschaftssanktionen sind ein starkes
Instrument dass wir sozusagen gewaltfrei
einsetzen können gegen Diktator Wladimir
Putin und das sollten wir unbedingt auch
tun auch wenn es uns möglicherweise in
bestimmte Maße auch schadet ich glaube
es schadet uns mehr nachweislich als
Russland Putin hat noch nie mehr Geld
verdient mit seinen Exporten von Öl und
Gas wie aktuell Gazprom hat ein
Rekordgewinn verbucht also der der Rubel
rollt muss man tatsächlich Leiter sagen
und wir leiten darunter wir sehen dass
die deutsche Industrie immer mehr rechts
und dass sie auch schon versuchen ins
Ausland abzuwandern das ist eine große
Gefahr und wir können Wohlstand mehr
haben dann können wir auch die Ukraine
nicht unterstützen wir können nicht die
grüne Transformation vorantreiben wir
können kein Bürgergeld implementieren es
wird uns allen klar sein und die
Sanktion zu beenden ist nur ein Punkt
den ich kritisiere sehr viele weitere
Punkte wir müssen jetzt die Ideologie ad
acta legen weil wir hatten es jahrelang
eigentlich eine Art verblendeten
Dogmatismus in der Politik also
Atomausstieg eine völlig überhastete
Energiewende die definitiv geschaltet
ist ein Trümmerhaufen ist die bankrotte
Erklärung schlechthin die wir gerade
erleben sondern dass wir jetzt den
mathematismus und den Schutz der Bürger
und der Bevölkerung der sozialen
Friedens über diese Ideologien stellen
das wird sagen wir müssen einfach neue
Wege beschreiben die Atomenergie die ist
nicht nur emissionslos und grün geadelt
von der EU nein die ist auch hoch
effizient Ideologie Adapter gehe ich mit
aber trotzdem gegen Putin sollten wir
tun was immer wir können das halte ich
für richtig dass sie wegen Liebe auf
lngas Setzen von mir aus sogar und so
weiter aber nicht putin ist auch das
Geld in die klassenspülen damit er
diesen Wahnsinn weil wir kaufen das Öl
von Putin trotzdem halt über Drittländer
wie zum Beispiel durch China sehr völlig
absurd aber wir können lange darüber
reden fakt ist ich glaube nicht dass
Waffenlieferungen im Krieg beenden am
Sanktionen kann man darüber reden ich
glaube nur die Sanktionen haben uns mehr
geschadet der westlichen Welt als sie
Russland geschadet haben
welche Zahlen anschaut sehe ich einfach
rekordsteuereinnahmen Rekord Umsätze mit
Öl Gas und anderen Rohstoffen die
Russland gerade verbuchten dann auch
eins zu eins wieder die Kriegswirtschaft
in finanzieren kann das ist das Ganze
Paradies Russland was sie da beschreiben
das höre ich also deutlich anders also
da bin ich die Zahlen an von Gazprom
schauen sich die 158 Milliarden im
zweiten Quartal aber daseinnahmen die
russische Wirtschaft getroffen wurde von
den Sanktionen das stimmt also stimmt
definitiv Fakt es ist ja nicht so als
hätte die russische Wirtschaft der ging
es jetzt besser als vor den Sand zu das
stimmt nicht wir wurden
selbstverständlich auch getroffen aber
da gehe ich hier auch mit dass die
russische Wirtschaft natürlich schon
leidet und es gibt auch Experten die
sagen es wird länger dauern bis die in
Gänze wirken die Sanktionen aber die
Frage an Herrn Patzelt die ich noch sehr
sehr spannend finde ist natürlich die
d-industrialisierung Deutschlands kommt
es jetzt wirklich nur durch die
Sanktionen ist es nicht schon ein viel
längeres Vorspiel hat es jetzt wirklich
nur der Ukraine Krieg ausgelöst dass wir
eigentlich als Wirtschaft immer
schwächer werden das Problem ist dass
hier viele Fehlentscheidungen und
Fehlentwicklung der Vergangenheit
zusammenkommen oben drauf gibt es die
extreme Verteuerung der Energiepreise
die nun Aluminium und Hersteller
chemische Industrie
betrifft Deutschland wir waren bei den
Energiepreisen ein sehr
wettbewerbsfähiges Land wozu nicht
zuletzt unsere Atomkraftwerke beim Strom
und eben auch das billige Gas aus
Russland beigetragen hat und beides ist
nun durch politische Entscheidungen
unterbunden weder gibt es billiges Gas
aus Russland noch wollen wir
Atomkraftwerke weiter laufen lassen aber
es kommen noch weitere Entscheidungen
oder fehlentwickeln dazu es ist zum
einen die schon auf die späten 60er
frühen 70er Jahre zurück in der
Vorstellung dass im Grunde die Industrie
es ist die unser Leben bedroht wir haben
einen zu großen ökologischen Fußabdruck
wir machen zu viele Emissionen es ist
die Industrie die sozusagen viel an
Lebensqualität verhindert da kommen
deutsche romantische Vorstellungen von
waldluftwiese alles grün die Sonnenblume
ist er nicht umsonst ein so ikonisches
Zeichen der Grünen geworden wir wollen
zurück zur Natur die rauchenden Schlote
dürfen nicht mehr sein der blaue Himmel
über dem Ruhrgebiet ist Gott sei Dank
inzwischen erreicht aber jetzt müssen
wir die Restbestände an Industrie
beseitigen das ist es aber auch noch
nicht
ganz wesentlich ist das
Ausbildungssystem Industrie können Sie
nur dann betreiben wenn sie Facharbeiter
haben Facharbeiter brauchen
Verlässlichkeit Ausdauer unser
Ausbildungssystem in Deutschland war ja
eigentlich lange Jahre von vielen
Ländern auch beneidet also es
Ausbildungssystem in Deutschland war ja
wirklich einzigartig in der
Vergangenheitsform aber wenn Sie sich
ansehen was die etlichen
Bildungsreformen in Deutschland an zehn
Prozent Abbrecherquote bei den
Ausbildungen Deutschland eben
Abbrecherquoten Senkung des
Bildungsniveaus war Rechtschreibung will
ich gar nicht reden wie es aussieht
kopfrechnung im Maler Berufen vielleicht
nicht ganz unnötig um auszurechnen wie
viele Farbe man für welche
Quadratmeterzahl braucht können einen
auch können einem auch
Schreckensgeschichte erzählt werden und
im Bildungssystem haben wir die
Vorstellung durchgesetzt das eigentlich
der Mensch erst ab dem Akademiker
beginnt das heißt Facharbeiter oder gar
Zuarbeiter das kommt nicht in Frage und
wenn sie dann auch noch den Lohndruck
und den abgabendruck und den Bürokratie
Druck auf die Unternehmen zu erhöhen wie
das in Deutschland der Fall ist Laden
haben sie sozusagen das gesamte
Horrorszenario beisammen damit haben sie
ja die falsche Anspruchshaltung
angesprochen jeder muss studieren
Ausbildung ist nichts mehr wert aber
frisch vielleicht wird sie gerne mal
fragen ist es vielleicht auch so zu viel
Gender Studies zu also zu wenig
Ingenieurwesen zu viel Gender Studies ja
ich glaube dass das Thema
Naturwissenschaften und Mathematik in
Deutschland einfach total unterbewertet
wird es ist hier bei uns immer noch
schick sagen zu können in Mathe war ich
immer schlecht oder mit Statistik kann
ich nichts anfangen ja und das wird mit
dazu dass wir die Digitalisierung in
Deutschland einfach verschlafen und ich
finde ihn ganz wichtigen Punkt
Digitalisierung
datendatenwissenschaften heißt nicht nur
Akademiker was wir nicht geschafft haben
ist in unserer Ausbildungssystem
genügend neue Berufe zur einzuführen die
sich mit Daten und Digitalisierung
auseinandersetzen denn es braucht nicht
nur studierte datenwissenschaftler um
mit dem Thema Digitalisierung und Daten
umzugehen und hier die Wirtschaft
voranzubringen ins 21 Jahrhundert
sondern wir brauchen da auch sehr sehr
viele Fachkräfte dafür haben wir aber
keine entsprechenden Ausbildungsberufe
und wenn nicht mehr überlegt wie lange
es dauert ein neuen Ausbildungsberuf bei
der IHK einzuführen da können wir mal
locker mit fünf Jahren rechnen ja und
dann ich meine das ist die Technologie
schon wieder veraltet ja dann brauchen
wir eigentlich schon wieder den nächsten
und das haben wir total verschlafen und
da müssen wir wirklich auch dieses
System wie schaffen wie halten wir
eigentlich Schritt mit der Entwicklung
neuer Technologien und passen unser
Bildungssystem entsprechend an diesen
Schritt den haben wir den müssen wir
auch schaffen heute kam auch noch eine
andere Studie raus und zwar es wird
jedem fünften Kind in Deutschland nicht
mehr vorgelesen also jedes fünfte Kind
in Deutschland kommt nicht mehr in den
Genuss dass ihm vorgelesen wird anhand
der Zahl Sebastian Geister sind
vielleicht auch die Eltern damit schon
in der Erziehung schuld dass Deutschland
immer weiter abdriftet egal wo steigert
hat mal das Buch schon früh geschrieben
Abstieg eines Superstars es gibt ganz
viele Faktoren also wenn man allein
bedingt wenn Menschen ständig junge
Menschen am Internet hätten am hängen am
Handy Instagram die
Aufmerksamkeitsspanne die immer geringer
wird immer nur für irgendwelche kleinen
Schnipselchen nur noch reicht das ist
glaube ich sehr schädlich
akademisierungswahn gehe ich voll mit
also warum ist das ist das notig wir
hatten ein sehr gutes Ausbildungssystem
in Deutschland ich würde sagen
Meisterbrief ist eigentlich mehr wert
als die mal also als zahlreiche Master
Bachelor ja ja oder so Handwerk hat
goldene Boden das sehen wir jetzt haben
wir die den Fachkräftemangel wir
produzieren im Grunde eher arbeitslose
Akademiker vielfach es kann nicht jeder
gender beauftragte werden Gott sei Dank
verdienen auch meistens mehr Handwerker
verdientes Geld wenn sie am Ende
vielleicht sogar eigene Betrieb haben
und so weiter schaffen selbst
Arbeitsplätze das ist was damit kann man
durchaus gutes Auskommen haben ich würde
sogar fast sagen manche können reich
werden damit das ist eigentlich sehr
attraktive sollten das attraktiver
machen und die Menschen auch besser
ausbilden und nicht Leute in solche
Orchideenfächer an der Uni schicken
Gender Studies und so ein Unsinn aber
die werden sich durch die kommende Krise
auf jeden Fall auflösen weil ich glaube
tatsächlich dass Deutschland vor der
größten Krise seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
steht durch die insolvenzquelle die
droht durch die die Industrialisierung
durch die Unternehmen der Mensch dann
der meistens durchschaltet haben drüber
gesprochen hat die die Menschheit ist
seit jeher eigentlich geprägt durch
Krisen und Krisen bringen einen weiteren
eigenen Biografie schon man hat mit den
größten Lerneffekt die erste Fünf in
Mathe bei ihnen ne oder
zuerst enttäuschte Liebe und so weiter
das heißt anscheinend ja wir müssen wir
müssen ja wir müssen wahrscheinlich erst
scheitern bevor wir dann wirklich neue
Wege einschlagen und es ist nicht
einfach weil jetzt muss man diese
Ideologie teilweise über Bord werfen
müssen neue Wege beschreiben vielleicht
müssen wir über Fracking reden
vielleicht müssen wir über Kohleabbau
wieder reden den wir erst zuvor mit
Milliarden an Subventionen beerdigt
haben also wir müssen ja die
Energieversorgung sicherstellen aber wir
sind ein energieintensives Land wir
haben Wirtschaft wie papierglas Metall
Automobilbau die brauchen Energie muss
auch günstig im wettbewerbsfähig sind
ansonsten müssen wir den Wohlstand
einfach ade linken und dann kann man das
Bürgergeld auch gleich Adapter legen
weil dann ist ja Ende Gelände und das
ist natürlich auch der Spaltpilz für die
Gesellschaft und dann kommen wir
natürlich auch nach zu ihrem Thema ne
das sind scheitern ja eher unsympathisch
ich habe jetzt sehr unbeliebt in der
Runde ich glaube es fehlt eine Akzeptanz
und ein Respekt seitens der Politik ich
denke dass das ein ganz großes Problem
ist da und Sebastian Geißler heute auch
sein Thema des Tages mitgebracht wie
respektvoll die Politiker eigentlich so
sind den Bürgern gegenüber ja an einem
Punkt dass er dich ziemlich respektlos
liebe Zuschauer schauen Sie mal ich war
sehr auf der Zehner als ich folgen und
von den Auftritt von unserem
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz gesehen habe
also zunächst mal toll dass sie eine
Bäckerei haben
und ich hoffe dass wir mit dem was jetzt
beschlossen ist und dem was wir jetzt
Morgen auf den Weg bringen werden auch
die Grundlagen dafür geschaffen werden
dass sie mit den furchtbar hohen
Energiepreisen umgehen können neulich
war kam jemand zu mir und sagte Herr
Scholz ich habe meinen Elektroofen
gerade auf ein Gasofen umgestellt und
habe ich wusste ich gar nicht wie
traurig ich gucken sollte
also lieber Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz
ich muss wirklich sagen unsere
Existenzen sind kein Witz das haben wir
hier gerade gesehen also der Kanzler ist
in einer Bürgersprechstunde und
schildert hier gerade das Schicksal
eines Beckers der ihm gesagt hat Mensch
ich habe vor ein paar Jahren noch
ausgerechnet auf einen Gasofen mich
umgestellt ja warum wie kann er denn
darüber jetzt ernsthaft Lachen das ist
doch nicht zum Lachen ich weiß dann
heißt es aus seinem Umfeld ja das war ja
in einem anderen größeren Zusammenhang
so nein nein er schildert das hier und
er lacht da vollkommen unpassend es ist
ja so die Politik hat uns in
Abhängigkeit geführt von Putins Russen
Gas ein riesiger Fehler ein schwerer
Fehler das ging los oder Kanzler
Schröder Merkel hat das voll weiter
forciert da gibt es noch Bilder wie sie
da irgendwie den Gas haben quasi
aufdreht mit den Russen zusammen
Katastrophe wer waren denn Vizekanzler
das war Olaf Scholz deswegen muss man
hier auch sagen eigentlich wäre es
angebracht dass die Menschen die dafür
Verantwortung tragen und ja er ist einer
davon vielleicht nicht unmittelbar in
seinem Verantwortungsbereich aber er war
einer der an vorderster Stelle in der
deutschen Politik mit auch dafür
Verantwortung getragen hat angemessen
wäre eher eine Entschuldigung dafür und
keineswegs dass man so sich jetzt hier
irgendwie noch heiter zeigt bei einem
solchen Thema und es ärgert mich auch
vor einem persönlichen Hintergrund mein
Vater hat vor drei Jahren tatsächlich
auch eine Gasheizung eine neue noch
einbauen lassen für satten fünfstelligen
Betrag jetzt sitzt man da mit dem
Schaden jetzt sagt uns die Politik
wieder ja Wärmepumpe wäre eigentlich
toll wäre dann auch wieder sehr teuer
das macht mich also wirklich ein
bisschen böse wenn ich unseren Kanzler
hier so sehe der ja angetreten ist zur
Bundestagswahl mit dem Slogan Respekt
für dich also wo bleibt der Respekt vor
dem Normalbürger an der Stelle wo bleibt
der Respekt vor z.B eine Bäcker der
jetzt um seine Existenz kämpft
fröscheler wo bleibt der Respekt vor dem
Normalbürger oder sagen Sie das war nur
ein Fettnäpfchen kann Politiker mal
passieren nein ich sehe das gleiche ja
in der in der Politik was Corona angeht
was uns da vorgesetzt wird teilweise wo
man einfach nur sagen muss ist das
haarsträuben der Unsinn der uns
teilweise von der Politik erklärt wird
oder auch die Tatsache dass wir bis
heute keine vernünftigen Daten haben um
die Pandemie zu oder uns behauptet wird
es würde ausreichend Fallzahlen zu
messen Inzidenzen zu müssen
reproduktionszahlen aber viele andere
Bereiche unseres täglichen Lebens
Wirtschaft Bildung psychosoziale Folgen
was unsere Kinder darunter leiden das
wird uns alles vorenthalten dazu kommen
ja noch auf Corona auf ihren Komplex wir
bleiben einmal bei dem Thema von Herrn
Geißler und ich würde jetzt mal Fragen
hier Herr Friedrich was sagen sie dazu
also Fettnäpfchen oder kann man sagen
darf eigentlich nicht passieren es zeigt
eine gewisse Hybris und eine
Echokammer eigentlich rüberkommen er
wollte glaube ich witzig sein aber ich
glaube dass Olaf Scholz jetzt nicht
gerade der Sympathiebolzen schlechthin
ist und irgendwie ein Witzbold ist aber
er sieht man mal über was er lacht
anscheinend fakt ist uns wurde
tatsächlich vor Jahren gesagt Leute baut
Gas an der Gas ist viel
umweltfreundlicher und es haben
Millionen Deutsche tatsächlich gemacht
jetzt sind wir diese Abhängigkeit ich
erinnere mich auch noch eine Rede von
sogar Donald Trump vor der UN da hat er
mich gewarnt für diese Abhängigkeit von
den Russen und er hat damals Herr Maas
Heiko Maas in ausgelacht eigentlich und
es ist genauso passiert wie erst
eigentlich gesagt hat und Millionen
Deutsche sitzen jetzt auf diesen teuren
Gasrechnungen wissen nicht wie sie
bezahlen soll und es wird er sich erst
ausspielen im Jahr 2023 und dahingehend
sieht man einfach diese Hybris diese
Abgehobenheit der Politik die nichts mit
der Realität zu tun haben und ich glaube
das fördert natürlich dann protestwinde
oder unzufriedene Bürger die dann
irgendwelche extremen Parteien wählen
das ist brandgefährlich von zur
Demokratie
Sebastian was würdest du dir denn
wünschen einen Entschädigungsfond für
diejenigen die das die den Gasofen
angeschafft haben oder was gibt es da
für dich wo du sagst neben dem Respekt
was die Politik besser machen kann ich
finde es gibt durchaus so was wie
private persönliche Lebensrisiken das
heißt man kann ja auch nicht alles von
Privatpersonen und Privathaushalten
immer fernhalten das ist jetzt eben so
auch in meinem Fall damit mein Vater mit
der Gasheizung sitzen wir jetzt halt
damit da ist jetzt einfach so ich bin
kein Freund immer von dieser ganzen
Umverteilung also dass man sagt
irgendwie aus der einen Tasche ziehen
raus aus der anderen Tasche gibt es
jetzt mal 300 € energiegeld und das
wieder und das ich möchte eher die
Staatsquote runterfahren ich finde man
sollte bei den Steuern mal entlasten und
ich bin sogenannten diese sogenannten
entlastungspakete das ist immer so eine
Zwangsbeglückung es wäre gut mal die
Steuerlast runterzufahren wäre glaube
ich ja für die Wirtschaft für die
Dynamisierung dieses ganzen Landes
eigentlich der richtige Schritt und das
würde ich mir wünschen aber der Respekt
der fehlt dir ja also wenn Olaf Scholz
sagt Respekt für dich das war ein
relativ respektloser Auftritt den er
dahin gelegt hat Herr Patze dieser
respektlose Auftritt da fragt man sich
immer sie sind Politikwissenschaftler
und ich frage mich mal hatte die Politik
früher mehr Respekt haben wir jetzt nur
das Gefühl der Respekt ist weg wie hat
sich das entwickelt früher waren die
Beziehungen zwischen Bürgerschaft und
Politik etwas weiter auseinandergezogen
das Politiker im Bürgersprechstunden
gehen und dass das im Fernsehen oder in
irgendwelchen sozialen Medien übertragen
wurde das war so nicht der Fall wirklich
war die Menge der Situationen in denen
man sich sozusagen nach missverständlich
ausdrücken oder in ein Fettnäpfchen
setzen oder seinen wahren Charakter
wieder eigenes wollen im doch zu
erkennen geben konnte wesentlich
reduzierter da hat sich tatsächlich
unter dem Eindruck von Medien das
politische System verändert ganz
wesentlich ist aber auch zu begreifen
dass die Politik insbesondere die
Spitzenpolitik weiterhin ein sehr
intüchtiges Geschäft ist man muss
aufeinander reagieren und man muss auf
die Medien über die man ja politik
spielt reagieren das heißt man achtet
sehr darauf welche Themen sind im Moment
gerade anzusprechen auf welche Weise
muss ich welches Thema ansprechen früher
war klar da sitzt billig und die Russen
haben sogar während des Kalten Krieges
verlässlich geliefert und das ist dann
auch sozusagen nicht so gefährlich wie
die Atomenergie wo er ständig die
atommeile in die Luft gehen und die Welt
verstrahlen infolgedessen war es damals
ganz üblich zu sagen Freunde setzt auf
Gas inzwischen ist Gas ganz schlecht
weil es ganz teuer ist und es kommt auch
von den Russen und so weiter das heißt
auf das was jeweils gängig ist das was
jetzt jeweils sozusagen erwartet wird um
soziale Prestige Punkte als Politiker zu
gewinnen darauf reagiert man im übrigen
verweise ich darauf beim Thema
Abgehobenheit oder wir gehen Bürger wir
gehen Politiker mit den Bürgern um
unter hochschullehren sagt man die
Universität wäre schön wenn es keine
Studenten gäbe und der Politikern sagt
man Politik ist schön solange es keine
Wahlen gibt verstehen sie auf
Landesebene wurde die Wahlperiode auf 5
Jahre alt halten verlängert mit dem
Argument dann können wir länger
Sacharbeit machen und auf Bundesebene
wird das auch erwogen das heißt damit
man ja den Störfaktor Bürger nicht mehr
so hautnah spürt und das ist schief
gegangen eine politische Klasse die ganz
wesentlich um sich selber kreist nicht
darum die Bürger denn wenn die aufmüpfig
werden sind da bloß Populisten und um
die muss man sich eh nicht kümmern aber
sie haben angesprochen dass es früher
mehr Entfernung gab zwischen Bürger und
der Politik was man aber ja sagen muss
früher waren die Politiker ja gefühlt
näher bei den Bürgern Edmund Stoiber
lebt in der doppelhaushälfte in
Wolfratshausen Frau Merkel hat jetzt
auch nicht in der riesigen Villa gewohnt
also da hat sich Politik doch weiter vom
Bürger entfernt wenn man zum Beispiel an
ihren spahnsinner denkt oder auch an
andere luxus-sachen naja ich würde
vorschlagen dass jetzt nicht an
einzelnen Wohnobjekten festzumachen ein
nennenswerter Teil von Politikern
insbesondere von Abgeordneten lebt auch
durchaus in ganz normalen Verhältnissen
nein nein es hat eher wirklich damit zu
tun dass sie in den Politikbetrieb immer
auf das reagieren müssen was in dem
Politik Betrieb drinnen ist und seitdem
es diese Schere Kluft ist vielleicht zu
viel gesagt aber diese Entfernung diese
psychische Entfernung der Bürgerschaft
von der Politik gibt und die Politik
sich von der Bürgerschaft eher gestört
empfindet seitdem der Fall ist werden
dann Politik auch sehr linkisch im
Umgang mit Leute seit wann ist das
konkret der Fall ja das ist seitdem so
Sendungen wie zur Sache Kanzler aus
wahlkampfgründern in der späten
kohlphase erfunden worden sind seitdem
dann Regionalkonferenzen in den Parteien
unumgänglich wurden seitdem Parteitage
durch inszeniert werden und seitdem eine
Bundeskanzlerin namens Merkel das
Erlebnis hatte dass sie einem Mädchen in
einer Fernsehsendung sozusagen
hartherzig kam und die Gewalt dann ihre
vollständige politische Richtung in
Sachen Migration verändert hat an der
Stelle fingen an Politiker zu merken es
kann gefährlich sein mit dem Bürger und
umzugehen und im Zweifelsfall versuche
ich dann denen nach dem Munde zu reden
oder und oder witzig zu sein und wenn
man nun nicht gerade der größte Witzbold
der Republik ist dann geht das schief
wie unlängst bekannter Scholz Herr
Friedrich sind also jetzt
zusammenfassend die Medien eigentlich
schuld weil die zu viel Nähe zur Politik
haben und die Politiker denken jetzt sie
müssen Charismatiker werden
wahrscheinlich auch der Druck der
sozialen Medien ist enorm ne man
versucht halt Klicks zu generieren über
tiktok und Instagram und Social Media
und viele haben sie schon die Finger
verbrannten haben wieder die ganzen
sozialen Plattformen verlassen ne aber
Fakt ist man sieht hat Robert Habeck hat
sich zurückgezogen viele viele natürlich
klar weil die einfach gemerkt haben ist
kreiert dann auch ein Shitstorm
teilweise man geht schnell in
Fettnäpfchen rein aber man sieht halt
auch diese Abgehobenheit tatsächlich und
ich meine früher wenn jemand ein Fehler
gemacht hat ist noch zurückgetreten es
gibt gar nicht mehr ich frage mich immer
wann treten eigentlich Politikerin mal
zurück ne manche Rücktritt ist von der
Sache nicht begründet
manche Rücktritt wäre von der Sache
begründet und das Problem ist dass die
meisten Politiker wegen Kleinigkeiten
zurücktreten ein Bundesinnenminister
trat einmal zurück weil er einem
SPD-Kollegen gesagt hat passt auf macht
den nicht zum Innenminister denn bei dem
Schwert ein Verfahren da musste der
Innenminister zurücktreten bei großen
Sachen wie eine völlig falschen
Energiepolitik oder Corona Politik wählt
man nicht die Regierung ab sondern einen
der diese Politik mitgetragen hat wählt
man sogar zum Bundesrat
arabische Sprichwort dass ich immer
wieder dann nenne ist nämlich ich glaube
ein Schaf und du wirst gehängt glaube
1000 Schafe du wirst gefeiert das ist
anscheinend das Motto momentan in
Brüssel und in Berlin
und du kannst dich entschuldigen und
sagen ja es war falsch aber wir sollten
keine Schuldzuweisungen machen wir
machen einfach weiter genau jede DDR ist
das man muss nach vorne diskutieren
keine Fehler Diskussion nach vorne
diskutieren und an dieser Stelle sind
wir gelehrliche Schüler und wir sehen
Sozialismus vorwärts immer rückwärts
immer und das ist Sozialismus deswegen
haben wir gerade zumindest überall zu
sehen die Regierung in ihrem Lauf halten
weder
Lauterbach ja so jetzt haben wir auch
hier viele Rezepte gemacht die letzte
Frage zur These von Sebastian Geißler
geht natürlich an Sebastian Geist und
das ist die Frage muss denn jetzt herr
Scholz für den Witz zurücktreten
hätte das auch nicht sagen sondern ich
finde es hat eine Geisteshaltung
offenbart während so einer Stelle lachen
muss sehr schwierig sehr schwierig sehr
schwierig Note
4 - 5 4 - 5 vielleicht kann er es mit
einer guten Tassen arbeiten
gleich nach einer kurzen Unterbrechung
weiter und geben jetzt in die Werbung ab
mit einer 4 - für Olaf Scholz bis gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist das fast
totalitär das sieht ja toll
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst das Problem ist nicht
dass wir zu wenig Stadt haben wir haben
zu viel Staaten wenn die alle wegfallen
und wir uns gegenseitig in Berlin mit
der Cappuccinos verkaufen das
funktioniert nicht dann ist mit
Wohlstand aber das ist alles Essig als
freiheitsliebender Mensch würde ich
sagen das muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und um Währungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss noch
was machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt mit dem Gerät
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und machen direkt
geschwind weiter um keine Zeit zu
verlieren mit der These von Werner
Patzelt
ich habe das Thema aufgebracht
Proteste in Deutschland ich hoffe zeigen
nicht dass er seinen Protest Winter
geben wird ich wäre aber auch nicht
überrascht wenn die Proteste im Winter
zunehmen wichtig ist dass man nicht nur
die Oberfläche des Geschehens ansieht
sondern begreift wie sich das nun seit
etlichen Jahren aufschichtet denken wir
zurück an die Unzufriedenheit oder
besser gesagt an die Sorgen vieler
Deutschen ob der deutschen Rolle in der
euro-rettungspolitik Übernahme von
Bürgschaften Garantien für dieses und
jenes nach der
eurozonenpolitik kommt dann die große
Migrationspolitik wir schaffen das und
es ist unmöglich eine Obergrenze von
etwa 200.000 Leuten pro Jahr die wir
aufnehmen einzuführen inzwischen haben
wir 200.000 Asylbewerber heuer und dazu
wohl 1,1 Millionen Ukraine wir schaffen
das doch alle und dann kommen Briefe von
Landräten und fragt sich der Bürger ob
wir das wirklich schaffen dann kommt
oben drauf auch noch die
Schwerpunkt der Energie und die deutsche
Haltung im ukrainekrieg bzw korrekter in
Krieg Russlands gegen die Ukraine an
dieser Stelle fragen sich viele Bürger
weist die Politik eigentlich was sie tut
ist es wirklich wohl überlegt
Atomkraftwerke abzuschalten wenn man
anschließend ein stabiles Netz haben
will wo es ja eine bestimmte
Grundlastversorgung braucht die eben
durch die flüchtigen oder die unsteten
Energien Wind und Sonne nicht erzeugt
werden kurz um die Bürger fragen sich
weiß die Politik was sie tut deswegen
wurde dann immer wieder protestiert
diese Protestbewegung haben sich
aufeinander aufgeschichtet es gibt zum
Teil personelle Kontinuitäten und immer
mehr Leute kamen dazu und es zeigt sich
dass die alte Strategie die von Politik
und Medien gefahren worden ist ein
weniger und weniger verfängt als wir die
eurozonen Kritik hatten da war das
Argument wer nicht begreift dass der
Euro Europa zusammenhält und den Frie
gespeichert ist ein Europa Feind ein
europa-gegner und wir sind Europa Gegner
Nationalisten als die migrationskritik
kam da war die Aussage die gegen eine
bunte Gesellschaft können nur Rassisten
etwas haben also grenzt man sie aus als
dann die Proteste gegen die
corona-politik kommen da waren es
Extremisten die demokratische Politik
nicht akzeptieren wollen das heißt der
Staat ist allmählich hilflos in Bezug
auf diesen Bürgerprotest die alten
Rezepte funktionieren nicht mehr das
merken die Bürger wiederum und so sind
wir in einer aufschaukelnden Spirale und
wir alle warten darauf dass wir einen
Weg finden diese Spirale ändern zu
durchbrechen das ist tatsächlich ein
guter Punkt also man sieht immer mehr
wenn jemand gegens narrativ spricht wenn
jemand Kritik äußert dass man immer mehr
diffamiert wird stigmatisiert wird
gebrandmarkt wird dass man irgendwie ja
in irgendeine Schublade gesteckt wird um
nicht auf die Argumente einzugehen weil
man vielleicht auch keine Gegenargumente
hat man wird persönlich angegriffen weil
man dann sich der Argumentation nicht
hingeben und das ist eine
brandgefährliche Entwicklung für die
Debattenkultur und für unseren Diskurs
den wir eigentlich brauchen und dann
gibt es nicht mehr sie haben vollkommen
recht sobald man irgendwie wagt was zu
kritisieren wird man sofort diffamiert
und es ist daran krank unsere komplette
Gesellschaft und bei Corona was ganz
besonderes deutlich selten ein Blatt vor
den Mund das nie würde ich sagen ich
wollte ihn ja auf Twitter
dementsprechend ist mir also sympathisch
über dementsprechend die Frage erleben
Sie das auch persönlich dieses
diffamiert werden oder absolut etwas
dadurch auch verlieren ja jeden Tag
jeden Tag also durch meine Grundhaltung
dass ich halt von Anfang an skeptisch
war zum Beispiel bei den
corona-maßnahmen oder beiden
Euro-Rettungsmaßnahmen habe ich
natürlich sehr viel Gegenwind bekommen
teilweise auch Shitstorms und meistens
war es aber nicht fundierte
Gegenargumente sondern es war immer
eigentlich nur eine Art ja
Stigmatisierung ne nach dem Motto ja
redet nicht mit dem weil und so weiter
also dann hat man irgendwie versucht
jemanden irgendeine Schublade zu stecken
und daran krank unsere komplette
Debattenkultur seit Jahren wer Auszeit
muss auch einstecken können
dementsprechend ich bin aber sie Stör
ich bin absolut offen für für eine
konstruktive pluralistische Gesellschaft
und für den Austausch und für Kritik und
für konstruktive Kritik aber fundiert
und nicht irgendwie unter der
Gürtellinie oder persönlich diffamieren
nur nach dem Motto wenn man den jetzt
irgendwie sagen das ist ein Spur blau
oder irgendwie ein Querdenker dann muss
man erst gar nicht auf die Argumentation
eingehen das ist so einfach und das
sehen wir seit Jahren seit angefangen
mit der Euro-Krise whatever it takes
damals und als ich gesagt habe leute das
ist ein riesen Problem das geht nicht
wurde ich hart angegriffen genauso ist
auch während der corona-krise aber haben
wurden sie auch praktisch diffamiert
oder es ist glücklicherweise ja nur im
Netz und da wird ihn verloren also wenn
sie Wikipedia lesen oder so dann ist man
sofort irgendwie eher rechts einzuordnen
was ich wahrlich nicht bin und das ist
schon ein brandmarkt weil viele Google
halt erstmal am gucken aha Frau
Brockhaus und dann guckt mal was macht
ihr denn eigentlich so und da kommt man
irgendwann auf Wikipedia und das ist
schon ja Stigmatisierung finde ich der
Menschen und es geht so nicht wir müssen
mit den in wir müssen Brücken bauen dann
müssen wir dann reden das ist ja die die
Macht die die Menschen haben dass wir
kommunizieren können miteinander und
dass wir auch andere mein akzeptieren
wir hatten ja auch recht wir hatten ja
auch mit vielen Punkten recht weiter
Eurokrise mit der Inflation oder auch
bei Corona die ganze Wahrheit trifft
sich ja gerade ihren Weg Sachen die wir
vor allem wenn ich sagen durften da
werden wir gecancelt worden auf Youtube
dürfen wir jetzt sagen
wir wurden mit Fell nach noch nie auf
Youtube gecancelt und hier wurde alles
auf den Tisch gebracht muss ich sagen
also muss ich sagen ich lebe hier im
Reich der Meinungsfreiheit aber ich
stimme natürlich zu das ist der Probleme
gibt mit Kritikern die diffamiert werden
wie ist es denn bei dir Sebastian du
wirst wahrscheinlich nicht diffamiert du
bist auch natürlich ne also wenn man
alleine mal das Beispiel wenn ich jetzt
aber mal es gibt wieder irgendwo ein
leckeres
werden kannst also wenn alleine stehen
vor Messerattacke so etwas und dann
teilst du bei Facebook einen Text und
schreibst darüber das ist ja schrecklich
was da passiert ist so was passiert dann
dann kommen gleich Leute Mensch warum
interessiert dich das denn überhaupt und
so immer so verhörende Tore von wegen du
bist ja rechts und so da kommt da kommen
keine gegenargumen wenn ich aus der
verlängert muss man tatsächlich auch für
die Migrationspolitik in der Tat daraus
auch seine Ableitung treffen und sagen
kann ist es schon ein Problem wenn
Menschen aus sehr brutalisierten
Gesellschaften in großer Zahl kommen
manche denken
da kommt eine solche Keule Menschen
wenden sich ab in Freunden einen sagen
ach ist jetzt hier irgendwie rechts und
so das ist keine Diskussionskultur wir
müssen den anderen wieder achten wir
müssen inhaltlich diskutieren oder
innerlich gegenhalten und nicht sagen
das ist ein gefährlicher Spieler was hat
man in der Realität zu befürchten die
Frage gerne an sie beide an sie drei was
hat man in der Realität zu befürchten
also Twitter Shitstorms kenne ich zu
genüge ich habe da auch den Namen Masken
Nena weil ich immer gegen die
maskenpflicht war das akzeptiere ich
auch das Stufe ich aber unter Gegenwind
1 das finde ich gehört zur meinungsfrei
dazu ich kritisiere ja andauernd man
soll mich auch kritisieren Hass ist zwar
nicht gut aber ich nehme das hin ist es
denn in der Realität so dass sie
Probleme haben und wo sie sagen es geht
weiter ja tatsächlich also ich habe
tatsächlich Freunde verloren wirklich
gut ich dachte es wären gute
Freundschaften selbst innerhalb der
Familie gibt es eine Spaltung dass ich
nicht mehr auf feste eingeladen wurde
oder so weil ich eine starke Meinung
vertrete und natürlich habe ich auch
also wirtschaftlich Probleme gehabt dass
Kunden sich von mir abgewendet haben
oder sich böse Briefe bekommen oder oder
sowas sehr böse E-Mails teilweise mit
Drohungen und das ist dann schon wo ich
sage okay hier ist auch das ganze
überschritten aber ich spüre das oft
oder sie auch angesprochen werde im Zug
nach Berlin oder so nach dem Motorrad
sie sind doch der der gegen den Euro ist
und sie sind doch jetzt irgendwie in
Euro hasse und Nationalist und so Späße
also völlig absurd ne irgendwas
aufgeschnappt irgendwie nicht wirklich
verarbeitet und einfach nur raus posaunt
und das ist das Schlimme eigentlich
sobald man irgendwie versucht mal mit
Daten Fakten zu argumentieren dann
bekommt man gleich massiven Gegenwind
aber ohne Gegenargumente das stört mich
am allermeisten diese Diffamierung sie
kennen das auch Frau Schüller
selbstverständlich und das ist genau das
Problem man muss Fakten auch auf den
Tisch bringen können wenn sie anderen
nicht passen wir erleben das oft genug
in der unstatistik der Kolumne bei der
ich mit mitschreibe wo wir einmal im
Monat eine schlechte Statistik
auseinander nehmen wenn wir schreiben
dass die Impfwirkung von 90 Prozent
nicht heißt dass 90 Prozent der Menschen
geschützt sind vor Corona kriegen wir
Gegenwind wir würden die Menschen vom
Impfen abhalten wenn wir schreiben die
Korrelation zwischen Impfungen und
Übersterblichkeit ist es falsch es
statistisch falsch kriegen wir Gegenwind
von der anderen Seite als ich im August
2020 von einem Kollegen von ihnen BILD
am SONNTAG gefragt wurde ja wo geht es
denn hin mit den Fallzahlen bis Herbst
habe ich gesagt ja okay irgendwo 5000
bis 20.000 kam die Schlagzeile diese
statistikerin sagt wir hätten bis zu
20.000 Fälle im Herbst was ich an
E-Mails bekommen habe Panikmache und so
weiter also am Ende einfach nur noch
ungesehen gelöscht dann hatten wir
20.000 Fälle im Herbst auf einmal hieß
es das ist die statistikerin die 20.000
Fälle vorher gesehen hat ja aber man
muss solche Fakten einfach auf den Tisch
bringen das ist Mathematik das sind
Daten man kann solche Dinge berechnen
ohne dass man wahlweise als Verharmloser
oder als Panikmacher beschimpft wird wir
haben ja heute auch ein Thema
mitgebracht wo sie eventuell wieder ein
Shitstorm für bekommen können deswegen
herzlichen Dank dass Sie sich das
trotzdem trauen und damit sind wir bei
ihrer These heute Abend
ja ich bin der Meinung Deutschland ist
ein datenentwicklungsland das hat sich
in der corona-pandemie ganz deutlich
gezeigt und wir sind nach wie vor keinen
wirklichen Schritt weiter starten
Entwicklungsland heißt wir haben nach
wie vor keine geeigneten Daten um die
Pandemie oder weitere Krisen vernünftig
zu managen weil die Daten uns überhaupt
nicht die Wahrheit sagen was eigentlich
passiert ist sie oder was passiert sie
sind beschränkt auf den
Gesundheitsbereich wir wissen viel zu
wenig darüber was in der Wirtschaft
passiert was im Bildungsbereich passiert
welche psychischen Folgen Menschen
erleiden obwohl wir diese Daten
eigentlich haben könnten und noch dazu
kommt in den Bereichen wo wir Daten und
Studien haben werden uns diese Daten
vorgesetzt mit teilweise haarsträubenden
Fehlinterpretationen das geht ich nenne
nur ein paar Beispiele los September
2021 mit der Aussage der dritte die
dritte Impfung der Booster erhöht die
Schutzwirkung der Impfung um den Traktor
10 völliger Unsinn sie können einen
Schutz von 99,8% nicht verzehnfachen das
werden 1980 Prozent das ist nicht
möglich dann die Aussage jetzt im Sommer
Masken die mega maskenstudie 1700
Studien wurden untersucht der Nutzen der
Masken sei groß unumstritten und Geld in
vielen Bereichen schaut man genauer hin
wann es am Ende 13 Studien die überhaupt
nicht miteinander vergleichbar waren ja
die Masken wirken aber sie haben eine
relativ kleine Schutzwirkung dann geht
es jetzt wieder weiter im Oktober 11
Oktober Tweet von Lauterbach das
Oktoberfest hätte die Inzidenzen
befeuert beweist wir haben den Anstieg
in München und Bayern in Bayern der so
hoch nach oben geht was völlig ignoriert
wird ist dass das im praktisch allen
Bundesländern ähnlich gestiegen ist
Aussage dann aber wir werden an einer
maskenpflicht in Innenräumen im Winter
nicht vorbeikommen da frage ich mich
schon ob nicht zuerst die Überzeugung
weil wir brauchen die maskenpflicht und
dann hat man sich die Daten passen
gesucht und der neueste uns in den wir
jetzt haben ist diese Studie die
angeblich zeigt dass die bivalenten
Impfstoffe gegen noch zu erwartenden
neue Mutation dabei helfen würden auch
völliger Unsinn schaut man sich die
Studie mal genauer an dann ist
untersucht worden wie bereits existente
corona-varianten na klar andere haben
wir ja auch nicht wie da die Impfung
wirkt man sieht auch dort dass der
vivalente Impfstoff schlechter wirkt bei
verschiedenen Omicron Varianten
vielleicht minimal weniger schlecht als
die bisherigen monovalenten im Stoffe
aber auch da muss man sagen wenn man
dann noch mal genauer hinschaut am Ende
sind 12 Personen pro Gruppe die
untersucht worden sind das wird dann
wieder schön verschwiegen und da habe
ich das Gefühl uns wird vorgesetzt das
sei Wissenschaft das hat mit
Wissenschaft nichts zu tun also es
notiert immer mehr zu einer Pandemie der
Lügen und die Wahrheit bricht sich
tatsächlich ihren Weg sie haben es
völlig richtig gesagt ich finde es auch
faszinierend dass nicht mal 50 Prozent
der Patienten in den Krankenhäusern
überhaupt erfasst werden ob die geimpft
oder ungeimpft sind wie kann man dann
überhaupt mit Statistiken Arbeiten
beziehungsweise wenn dann wird es im
Privaten gemacht Vorbild Helios Kliniken
haben ihr eigenes impfregister angelegt
da kann man unglaublich im Studio draus
machen wird
aber von Charité und so weiter geflissen
ich ignoriert weil das sind ja privat
und die sind ja nur am Profit
interessiert dabei sind die praktisch
die einzigen die uns vernünftige Daten
liefern um zu verstehen was in den
Kliniken in Bezug auf Corona eigentlich
abgeht ihr Leben das Problem ist aber
wesentlich größer als der Umgang mit
Daten im Zusammenhang mit der
corona-pandemie im Hintergrund steht
eine ganz furchtbare Unbildung in Bezug
auf Statistik jeder stolz darauf dass an
der Schule von Mathematik nichts
verstanden hat und dass er das Fach froh
ist es nicht mehr machen zu müssen jeder
weiß von Statistik im Grunde nur den
dämlichen Spruch dass wir nur der
Statistik trauen soll die man selbst
gefälscht hat das glaubt man dann dass
mit Statistik immer nur verfälschen
umgegangen wird ab und zu kann man
natürlich doch Interpretationen sein
Argument stärken aber das ist dann so
wie es manchem Journalisten in der Mund
gelegt wird ich werde mir doch eine gute
Geschichte nicht durch allzu viele
recherchieren kaputt machen lassen
zum übelsten Beispiel geraten dann immer
wieder talkrundern wo dann jemand mit
Fakten kommt und dann eine abgewürgt mit
dem Hinweis darauf naja diese Fakten die
interessieren uns unsere Zuschauer nicht
zu sehr die können wir jetzt nicht
nachprüfen und derjenige der sich bemüht
Fakten einzubringen er steht dann am
Schluss als ein begossener Pudel aber
Statistik Bildung vor über 100 Jahren
eins meiner Lieblingszitate hat der
Autor der Zeitmaschine 11
Science-Fiction-Autor gesagt wenn wir
mündige Bürger in einer modernen
technologischen Welt wollen müssen wir
Ihnen drei Dinge beibringen lesen
schreiben und statistisches denken also
den vernünftigen Umgang mit Unsicherheit
und Risiken haben wir bis heute nicht
lesen schreiben übrigens Stichwort
Vorlesen wir haben in Deutschland 7
Prozent funktionale Analphabeten
Menschen die nicht in der Lage sind
einfacher Texte zu verfassen oder zu
lesen wem sollen die denn vorlesen und
auch das wird teilweise sie der falsch
dargestellt es gibt übrigens eine schöne
Darstellung der Volkshochschulen von
denen ich eigentlich relativ viel halte
die das so darstellen über 90 Prozent
der funktionalen Analphabeten der
Menschen die nicht richtig lesen und
schreiben können haben Deutsch als
Muttersprache der denkt man oh mein Gott
deutsch ist es Risiko dafür nicht lesen
und schreiben zu können falsch wir haben
einfach nur sehr viel mehr Menschen mit
Deutsch als Muttersprache in Deutschland
das Risiko nicht richtig lesen und
schreiben zu können ist deutlich höher
wenn sie nicht Deutsch als Muttersprache
haben oder wenn sie ihren Schulabschluss
abgebrochen haben aber wozu kommt diese
Studie durch ganz klare Verdrehung der
Daten bis sie passen nicht lesen und
schreiben zu können
illeetarat Analphabet zu sein kommt in
allen Gesellschaftsschichten vor mit
jedem Schulabschluss einfach eine
Verdrehung der Tatsache neben dem
journalistische ihre Verteidigung ist
auch im Journalismus oft so ist man
recherchiert vielleicht in eine
bestimmte Richtung und dann merkt man
nee so wie gedacht ist es nicht Thema
gestorben
Journalisten wird es in den Mund gelegt
und der Fall relotius hat schon
Wahrheit dabei ist tatsächlich müssen
auch die Medien durchaus ihre Bewohner
berichter
aufarbeiten stimme ich vollkommen Zuges
waren Dänemark gab es den Fall das gab
es die Zeitung die ist extra beladet ich
glaube sogar Boulevardblatt die haben
sich entschuldigt die haben gesagt
jawohl wir haben zu einer bestimmten
Zeitung angefangen praktisch nur noch
regierungsnarrative Regierungserklärung
zu übernehmen
nicht gefallen lassen dann kommt aber
die Entschuldigung der anderen Medien
Vertreter also ich glaube eine
Entschuldigung war eigentlich überfällig
in der Zwischenzeit vor allem auch von
Karl Lauterbach weil wie gesagt ich
glaube er macht wirklich Sherry picking
mit seinen Statistiken er sucht sich die
Daten raus die ihm gefallen und da bitte
sprich dem keiner dass er keiner zu
nehmen Sie mal die Statistiken Weg die
kann keine überprüfen
das ist doch die Frage prüfen Satz hier
in Spanien hat ja gesagt so heißt ja
auch sein Buch wir werden einander FIFA
zeigen müssen um zu verzeihen muss man
ja erstmal um Entschuldigung bitten dann
erst verziehen werden und da würde ich
dann doch noch mal Sebastian Geißler
Fragen mit Blick auf die Medien da muss
man ja auch selbstkritisch sein was gibt
es denn was die Medienhäuser wo die
unverzeihung bitten müssen also man hat
sicherlich zu stark bestimmte Zahlen z.B
einfach übernommen
gar nicht hinterfragt was bedeutet denn
er wert was bedeutet Inzidenz warum muss
denn die Inzidenz unter 50 bleiben jetzt
haben wir irgendwie wieder 1000 noch was
noch viel mehr Inzidenz ja man muss ja
sich klar machen was diese Zahlen auch
bedeuten und es gab ja so absurde
corona-maßnahmen das eine alte Frau
nicht mehr irgendwie auf der Bank sitzen
darf ein Buch lesen darf so das ist so
grotesk oder Menschen wir haben sie
gerade noch mal gesehen Menschen die
verfolgt werden von der Polizei im
Stadtpark glaube draußen mit der Maske
ja joggen ist doch was gutes für die
Gesundheit ja es kann doch nicht sein
das sind nämlich auch wieder Regen
gemacht worden von Politikern die
offensichtlich sehr gut bürgerlich
wohnen die sich gar keine Vorstellung
gemacht haben offensichtlich was es
bedeutet wenn ich mit einer Familie auf
in einer Dreizimmerwohnung oder als
Single sogar eine Einzimmerwohnung über
Wochen mich irgendwie da zu Hause
anschließen soll das ja ich gehe sogar
noch einen Schritt weiter und sagt er
mit einem verziehen werden kann muss man
vorab zu geben dass man möglicherweise
nicht alles weiß und dass man unter
Unsicherheit entscheidet und nicht zu
sagen ich habe hier eine Studie und ich
habe paar Daten und damit ist die
Entscheidung alternativlos das ist
nämlich das nächste Problem zu glauben
weil wir paar Daten haben wird uns die
Entscheidung abgenommen oder wir gehören
die Entscheidung ausrechnen und es fehlt
aber dann der Mut der Mut als Politiker
sich hinzustellen ich treffe hier eine
Entscheidung auch wenn ich nicht
hundertprozentig sicher bin was wichtig
ist weil hier ist ja das Gegenargument
ich habe aus als Vorbereitung für die
Sendung heute habe ich gestern einen
großen Social Media Post gestartet und
da eigentlich gesagt man müsste jetzt
das mal aufarbeiten 2G habe ich da jetzt
Beispiel genommen weil es für mich die
härteste Regelung war was ich fand für
die Bürger und da drunter waren aber
wirklich 50 Prozent Kommentare die
gesagt haben warum ich das jetzt wieder
raushole das wäre Boulevard clickbating
man sollte das jetzt nicht aufarbeiten
was soll denn damit erreicht werden und
da war ich schon schockiert und muss
sagen die die deutschen Medien schreiben
gar nicht so anders als die Bürger ist
auch in Social Media sehen
dementsprechend glauben Sie wirklich
dass es aufgearbeitet werden wird oder
dass die Bürger überhaupt wollen also
nicht die Frage ist möchten die Bürger
überhaupt das aufgearbeitet
sich unter ihrem corona-kurs oder ein
unter ihrem Post überhaupt melden
anderes Beispiel
Statistik die ich heute gesehen habe
Umfrage von der Welt welche der
ampelparteien die vernünftigste Politik
macht die SPD vier Prozent die Grünen
neun Prozent die FDP 42 Prozent naja das
sieht man jetzt nicht unbedingt in den
Wählerzahlen ja also da kann man dann
sagen die Stichprobe die hier wohl
geantwortet hat ist vermutlich nicht
repräsentativ also die ist wohl nicht
das was die Menschen für bessere Daten
ich werde verbessere Daten und darauf
nicht allen Daten die man bekommt
insbesondere auf Social Media einfach so
zu vertrauen sehr gut damit schließen
wir heute ich glaube nicht mehr meinen
eigenen Social Media Post wir sehen uns
morgen abend wieder und debattieren sie
doch auch zu Hause macht Spaß auch wenn
man anderer Meinung ist bis morgen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]